sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich wünsche
einen schönen guten morgen die sitzung
ist eröffnet
guten morgen
vor 100 jahren am 24 juni 1922
wurde walter rathenau ermordet
weil der liberale außenminister ein
bedeutender repräsentant der ersten
deutschen demokratie war und weil er
jude war und weil er für deutschlands
zukunft auf ausgleich und verständigung
setzte
der mord an rathenau war höhepunkt einer
serie von attentaten die die junge
weimarer republik erschütterte sie
entsprangen einem politischen klima von
hass hetze und gewalt es war keine tat
ihre geleitete einzelner der mord war
teil eines rechts terroristischen
umsturz planes der die republik zu fall
bringen sollte
das netzwerk reichte ihnen
rechtsnationale politische kreise und in
staatliche institutionen hinein der plan
scheiterte
stattdessen kam es zu nie dagewesenen
massenkundgebungen für die demokratie
allein in berlin gingen eine million
menschen auf die straßen am tag nach dem
mord erließ die regierung zwei
verordnungen zum schutz der republik es
schien als hätte die ganze republik
begriffen dass sie sich entschlossen
gegen ihre inneren feinde zur wehr
setzen muss wir wissen
am ende reichte das nicht heute richtet
sich unser blick auf den krieg den ein
aggressiver auto grad zurück nach europa
gebracht hat auf den kampf der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer um ihre
freiheit um ihr recht selbst zu
bestimmen wie sie leben wollen
dieser krieg ist auch ein angriff auf
die freiheitliche demokratie aber
demokratien sind und bleiben vor allem
von innen her verletzlich auch unsere
demokratie die sich seit mehr als sieben
jahrzehnten bewährt
polarisierung unversöhnlichkeit und eine
enthemmung in worten und taten setzen
ihr zu noch nie gab es so viele
politisch motivierte straftaten auch
antisemitische straftaten das ist
besonders beschämt
unsere freiheitliche gesellschaft wird
bedroht von verschwörungstheorien und
gezielter desinformation von hetze und
hass hass der zu den morden des nsu den
anschlägen von halle den toten von hanau
geführt hat hass der walter lübke im
juni vor drei jahren das leben gekostet
hat dem müssen wir uns entschieden
entgegentreten
mit allen mitteln und ich betone dass
auch mit blick auf unsere arbeit wir die
abgeordneten und zwar alle abgeordneten
sind für die politische kultur in diesem
land maßgeblich verantwortlich unsere
demokratie muss sich mutig und
entschlossen gegen ihre feinde zur wehr
setzen nach innen und nach außen das ist
die lehre die unser grundgesetz aus der
gescheiterten weimarer republik zieht
aber die geschichte lehrt noch etwas die
demokratie braucht vor allem
demokratinnen und demokraten es kommt
auf das engagement der bürgerinnen und
bürger für die freie demokratische
gesellschaft an heute nicht weniger als
vor 100 jahren
[Applaus]
nun kommen wir zur aktuellen
tagesordnung
interfraktionell wurde vereinbart dass
der tagesordnungspunkt 30 und der
zusatzpunkt 15 unter beibehaltung des
jeweiligen debatten zeit die plätze
tauschen
ich gehe davon aus sie sind damit
einverstanden
ich sehe keinen widerspruch dann ist das
so beschlossen
der abgeordnete dirk brandes hat
fristgerecht einspruch gegen den in der
letzten sitzung erteilten ordnungsruf
eingelegt dem einspruch wurde nicht
abgeholfen der einspruch wird als
unterrichtung verteilt gemäß § 39 der
geschäftsordnung ist der anspruch auf
die heutige tagesordnung zu setzen der
bundestag hat über den einspruch ohne
aussprache zu entscheiden die
entscheidung über den einspruch wird als
zusatzpunkt 16 nach tagesordnungspunkt 7
das ist gegen 10.20 aufgerufen
jetzt rufe ich die tagesordnungspunkte
7a und 7b auf die abschließende beratung
von vorlagen betreffend die aufhebung
des verbots der werbung für den
schwangerschaftsabbruch
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
68 minuten vereinbart ich eröffne die
aussprache und das wort hat für die
bundesregierung der bundesminister dr
marco buschmann
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
zuschauerinnen liebe zuschauer wir
beraten heute abschließend über den
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung zur
änderung des strafgesetzbuches aufhebung
des verbots der werbung für den
schwangerschaftsabbruch zur änderung des
heilmittelwerbegesetz
und zur änderung des einführungsgesetzes
zum strafgesetzbuch
das klingt maximal technisch das klingt
maximal abstrakt in wahrheit geht es
hier aber um etwas sehr bedeutendes
etwas sehr konkretes und etwas sehr
dringlich ist meine damen und herren wir
leben
wir leben heute in der digitalen
moderner und das bedeutet wenn eine
junge frau sich mit der schwierigen
frage eines möglichen
schwangerschaftsabbruch beschäftigt dann
wird sie in aller regel sich
informationen im internet beschaffen das
ist das niedrigschwellige angebot das
ist niedrigschwelliger als ich
vielleicht einem anderen menschen
vielleicht einem völlig fremden zu
offenbaren und dem internet kann
jedermann
selbst jeder troll und jeder
verschwörungstheoretiker alles mögliche
über schwangerschafts abbrüche
verbreiten aber dass wir hoch
qualifizierten ärztinnen und ärzten die
solche eingriffe vornehmen bei kriminal
strafe verbieten dort sachliche
informationen bereitzustellen
das ist absurd dass es aus der zeit
gefallen was ist ungerecht und deshalb
verändern wir die weichen stellen
dienen
haben
durchaus vorwurfsvoll mehr die frage
gestellt warum ich entschieden haben
dieses gesetzgebungsverfahren zu einem
der ersten gesetzgebungsverfahren dieser
bundesregierung und auch zum ersten
gesetzgebungsverfahren meines hauses zu
machen und die antwort auf diese frage
sie ist ganz einfach es ist höchste zeit
meine damen und herren es
ist höchste zeit für jede verurteilung
ärztinnen und ärzten jede weitere
verurteilung bis keine verurteilung zu
viel und die mehrheit zur änderung des
rechts sie war schon längst da die
arbeit hätte schon längst im letzten
deutschen bundestag erledigt werden
sollen das ging damals nicht aus
koalitions- politischen gründen aber
jetzt wo die mehrheit der fortschritts
koalition da ist ist es auch unsere
aufgabe sie zu nutzen um das recht auf
die höhe der zeit
ich möchte zwei sorgen nehmen die in
diesem zusammenhang immer wieder
artikuliert werden es wird immer wieder
die sorge geäußert dass damit der schutz
des ungeborenen lebens das schutzkonzept
des bundesverfassungsgerichts berührt
werden aber das schutzkonzept des
bundesverfassungsgerichts schlägt sich
im paragraph 218 jeder der ist 1995
entstanden nach einem gruppen
antragsverfahren hier im deutschen
bundestag § 209 10 a geht auf quälenden
debatten im kaiserreich in der weimarer
republik zurück und wurde 1933 durch die
erste nationalsozialistische
strafrechtsreform letztlich eingeführt
und schon diese unterschiede zeigen dass
man den schutz des ungeborenen lebens in
paragraph 218 und das informations
verbot für ärztinnen und ärzte streng
auseinander halten muss meine damen
es wird auch keine kommerzialisieren de
und kanalisieren de werbung geben dem
steht das berufsrecht ärztinnen und
ärzte entgegen und wir haben den
schwangerschaftsabbruch auch ins
heilmittelwerbegesetz aufgenommen und
dafür sorge getragen dass das nicht
passieren kann und deshalb möchte ich
mich an dieser stelle bedanken bei den
beamtinnen und beamten meines hauses bei
den kolleginnen und kollegen in der
bundesregierung die geholfen haben dass
wir schnell zu einem guten gesetzentwurf
der bundesregierung kommen und bei den
berichterstatterin und bericht erstatten
dieses hauses für die guten beratung ich
werbe für diesen entwurf es ist zeit für
mehr vertrauen in ärztinnen und ärzte
und es ist zeit für mehr
informationsfreiheit für frau herzlich
nächste rednerin für die
cdu/csu-fraktion elisabeth winkelmeier
becker
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrter bundesminister im
koalitionsvertrag
haben sie sich vorgenommen
wissenschaftliche evidenz und
evaluierung von gesetzen zum maßstab zu
machen für ihre kriminalpolitik mit dem
gesetzentwurf zur streichung von § 209
10 stgb werden sie dem selbstgesetzten
anspruch nicht gerecht es gibt keine
evaluation es gibt noch nicht mal ein
abwarten
auch in einer studie die zeitgleich im
bundesministerium der gesundheit
erstellt wird und die doch genau in den
blick nehmen will
ob es ausreichende beratung gibt wo es
defizite gibt dem greifen sie alle vor
das ist nicht am bedarf
orientiert
eine objektive eine sehe ich auch nicht
ich habe eher den eindruck dass es ihnen
darum geht hier ein erfolgserlebnis
zusammen zu produzieren weil sie eben an
anderen stellen auch mit vielen
problemen zu tun haben wie auch
verständlich
mehr
in koalitions-
gruppendynamik
dabei ist klar eine ungewollte
schwangerschaft
führt dazu dass eine frau macht sich
betroffen ist in ihren grundrechten in
ihrer selbstbestimmung
wir haben auf der anderen seite den
grundrechts konflikt mit dem
menschenrecht mit dem lebensrecht des
kindes das kann nicht in einem
klassischen kompromiss hoffnung ist
werden es geht immer um alles oder
nichts
jeder kann die situation der frau
nachempfinden denn jeder hat
wahrscheinlich auch in seinem
persönlichen umfeld einmal eine solche
situation erlebt aber wir denken eben
auch an das lebensrecht des kindes das
ist der maßgebliche unterschied denn ich
sehe zwischen uns dass der maßgebliche
grund weshalb wir an der geltenden
regelung festhalten wollen
aus den reihen der koalition haben wir
viele beiträge gehört sowohl die
rechnung auch in den social media in
denen das kind keine rolle spielt und
ich muss sagen an der stelle kamen wir
nicht zusammen
wir
erleben gerade mit blick auf die usa auf
polen wie dieser konflikt eskalieren
kann wir haben im jahr vor vielen jahren
auch bei uns gehabt
wir haben jetzt
wir haben jetzt in deutschland aber eine
gute geltenden regelung den dritten weg
der auf peter süssmuth zurückgeht und
vom bundesverfassungsgericht noch weiter
entwickelt worden ist der ebenso das in
verfahren dafür gesorgt werden muss dass
die rechte des kindes auch gegenüber der
frau eingebracht werden das ist das
wirksame schutz konzept das
bundesverfassungsgericht an dieser
stelle verlangt im mittelpunkt steht die
beratung und ergänzend dazu kommt das
werbeverbot denn es geht auch darum auch
das hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
ganz ganz ausdrücklich dafür zu sorgen
dass das bewusstsein dass das gespür für
das lebensrecht des kindes auch im
allgemeinen bewusstsein der gesellschaft
erhalten bleiben
und dafür ist das werbeverbot ein
wesentlicher faktor denn es geht
keineswegs nur um die frage sachlicher
information auf den homepages der erste
darum geht es nicht das sind immer die
beispiele sie gebracht werden aber es
geht viel weiter
mit der kompletten streichung von 4 auf
ermöglichen wir auch werbung aktive pro
aktive werbung im internet oder auch
möglicherweise in zeitschriften und das
suggeriert daneben das ist um eine ganz
normale ärztliche behandlung geht bei
der es nur um das wohl und wehe der
patientin des patienten geht und das
lieber herr bundesminister buschmann das
ist genau der unterschied diese
zusätzliche aussage die in der werbung
in der kombination von angebot und
informationen sie genau das ist das was
wir dann hinterher
das narrativ das ist hier ein defizit an
informationen gäbe ist falsch es ist
unsinn denn die realität ist doch die
realität ist doch dass jede frau jede
information im netz oder an anderer
stelle frei zugänglichen könnten das ist
auch in ordnung oder spricht überhaupt
nichts dagegen
gehen sie doch mal den suchbegriff
abtreibung ungewollt schwanger bei
google ein sie kriegen alle
informationen über methoden über
entwicklung des kindes und alle features
gehört wenn das hier ein defizit geben
wenn es kein defizit geben
dann hätte es der
bundesgesundheitsminister leicht in der
hand zum beispiel das angebot der
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung noch besser zu machen deren
homepage ist immer in den ersten treffer
wenn sie eine gute figur machen ist auch
völlig in ordnung so das heißt dass jede
information ganz leicht zugänglich ist
es ist offenbar falsch dass relevante
informationen vorenthalten würden wir
haben an einem anderen punkt keinen
dissenz
ärzte und ärztinnen müssen im rahmen der
beratungs lösen oder bahrain mit einer
integration ohne strafrechtliches risiko
schwangerschafts abbrüche deutsche
werden könnten das gehört zum konzept
der offenen beratung dass dann wenn sich
die frau für den abbruch entscheidet
diese auch durchgeführt und medizinisch
korrekt umgesetzt wird das setzt voraus
dass es auch ärzte gibt die das machen
und deshalb ist das völlig in ordnung
aber es ist auch zumutbar bei einem
konflikt bei dem wirklich grundrechte
auf beiden seiten
auszugleichen sind dass arztpraxen in
diesem fall auf werbung verzichten und
nur über andere ärzte über die
beratungsstellen hier gehen statt immer
offen bewerbung das ist ein sehr kleiner
eingriff in deren berufsfreiheit und mit
sicherheit verfassungsgemäß
wir lehnen es außerdem ab dass sie mit
dem gesetz rechtskräftige urteile seit
oktober 1990 pauschal kassieren
anscheinend wurde nichtmals überprüft
jedenfalls steht nichts dazu in der
gesetzesbegründung welche fälle das
waren und ob sie denn nach den neuen
regeln wenn überhaupt straffrei während
es kommt auch durchaus immer mal vorbei
gesellschaftlichen oder politischen
veränderungen dass dinge die früher
strafrechtlich sanktioniert wurden heute
nicht mehr für strafrechtlich relevant
gehalten werden trotzdem dürfen dann
nicht rechtskräftige urteile einfach
aufgehoben werden da gibt es eine sehr
sehr hohe hürde nämlich
nationalsozialistisches unrecht
sed-unrecht oder eben in letzter zeit
die aufhebung der verurteilung von
verurteilten nach paragraph 175 das
waren ausnahmen die das gerechtfertigt
haben aber damit kranken und traf zwar
nach 19a sicherlich nicht verglichen
werden
oder verschiedenen regierungen
einschließlich sozialer liberaler
koalition an schließlich rot grün noch
nicht angetastet sie wurde durchgehend
immer beibehalten sodass wir hier
sicherlich nicht sagen können dass ein
solches unrecht
vergleichbar ist zu den urteilen die
kassiert werden können
wir wissen dass frauen sich die
entscheidung nicht leicht gemacht wir
sollten sie in dieser entscheidung
unterstützen wir sollten hier helfen am
besten so dass wir ermutigen sich für
das kind zu entscheiden
und ansonsten in jedem fall helfen und
unterstützen verständnis zeigen für uns
heute hier heißt das dass wir dem
gesetzentwurf nicht zustimmen
elisabeth winkelmeier becker hat die
sichtweise der cdu/csu hier noch einmal
dargelegt die dagegen ist den paragrafen
219 tat zu streichen die mehrheit der
ampel aber will das ist auch schon ein
anschließendes fest oben in der fraktion
organisiert und deswegen kann man sicher
sein dass hier heute die abstimmung so
ausgehen wird dirk wiese der
stellvertretende zuständige
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd hat jetzt
hier für die sozialdemokraten heizen
nächste das wort und man hat jetzt schon
in den ersten minuten gemerkt dass die
stimmung hier aufgeladen ist auf beiden
seiten 218 ist immer ein aufreger thema
gewesen in den 17 und 19 jahren die
großen kontroversen in der gesellschaft
und das könnte natürlich auch hier heute
vielleicht weniger aber in zukunft der
fall sein wenn 218 eventuell wieder
aufgeschnürt werden sollte der devise es
219 strafgesetzbuchs durch die
ampelkoalition ist ein wichtiger schritt
zu mehr rechtssicherheit bei ärztinnen
und ärzten und zu einem verbesserten
zugang von frauen zur beratung und
betreuung ja zu den zugang von
informationen
wir setzen heute eine wichtige
vereinbarung unseres koalitionsvertrages
um und folgen damit auch der forderung
einer breiten mehrheit in der
bevölkerung und ich sage das ganz offen
hier das ist gut so gut dass wir das
heute als ampelkoalition voranbringen
die letzten jahrzehnte da müssen wir
ehrlich sein sind von einer deutlichen
und nüchtern in wahrheit geprägt verbote
führen bei einer so wichtigen und
persönlichen entscheidung nicht weiter
verbote führen nur dazu dass es
betroffenen frauen nur schwerer gemacht
wird selbst bestimmt für sich und ihre
familie zu entscheiden und damit muss
heute schluss sein
kolleginnen und kollegen unser heutiger
beschluss ist das ergebnis von
diskussionen engagement und ja auch
streit dabei ist die diskussion genau so
alt wie der abschnitt im strafgesetzbuch
selbst seit der einführung der
entsprechenden paragraphen in das
strafgesetzbuch und ist justizminister
buschmann hatte darauf hingewiesen des
deutschen reiches wird über sinn und
unsinn gestritten und es war vor über
100 jahren schon spd politikerinnen und
politiker um den späteren justizminister
gustav radbruch die für selbstbestimmung
und für einen verantwortungsvollen
umgang mit diesem sensiblen bereich sich
eingesetzt haben sie wussten schon
damals das restriktive gesetzgebung eben
nicht zu mehr schutz des ungeborenen
lebens wird sondern zur polarisierung
ama und mittelloser frauen die sich
keine verschwiegenen privatärzte schon
damals in teuren sanatorien leisten
konnten und wenn ich mir die aussagen
einiger kollegen und kolleginnen heute
auch vergegenwärtige dann muss ich das
so deutlich sagen ich habe manchmal den
eindruck der ein oder andere ist
gesellschaftspolitisch vor 100 jahren
stehen geblieben
und ich kann das sagen sie auch in der
opposition endlich ein neues kapitel auf
diese diskussion kann man nur mit den
betroffenen frauen gemeinsam führen wird
nicht gegen sie und es war übrigens
schon die sozial liberale koalition
unter willy brandt die beratungen über
die neufassung dieses abschnitts
eingeleitet hatte und gemeinsam schon
damals mit den frauen rechts bewegungen
nach wegen und lösungen gesucht hat es
war dann auch die wiedervereinigung die
zu einer großen herausforderung auf
diesem gebiet geführt hatte ich erinnere
nur daran dass es galt die in
ostdeutschland geltende fristenregelung
mit der im westen praktizierten
integrations regelung zu vereinfachen
das war nicht einfach aber ich bin
dankbar dass diese debatte damals wie
heute leidenschaftlich kontrovers aber
meistens auch immer mit respekt geführt
worden ist und mir persönlich sollte es
respekt ab wie würde voll viele frauen
diese diskussion führen konnten während
andere meinten entscheidungen über ihre
selbstbestimmung hinweg zu treffen
diesen respekt finde ich auch ärztinnen
und ärzte die sich in den vergangenen
jahren für einen ungehinderten zugang
von frauen zu informationen zum
schwangerschaftsabbruch eingesetzt dann
mit ihnen teilen wir die überzeugung
dass betroffene frauen und ihre familien
das recht auf professionelle beratung
und unterstützung durch behandelnden
ärztinnen und ärzte und der heutige tag
ist auch ihr verdienst und ich bin
dankbar dass wir uns heute bei dieser
debatte bei bonn
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
möchte zum schluss auch elfriede hofmann
inge wettig danielmeier elke ferner und
auch eva högl stellvertretend für viele
weitere genossinnen danken die sich in
den vergangenen jahren und jahrzehnten
unermüdlich für die selbstbestimmung der
frauen in diesem land eingesetzt haben
auch ihr einsatz trägt heute zur
streichung bis 219 stgb bei vielen dank
für die aufmerksamkeit
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion
thomas seitz
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren ersten lesung
hatten wir schnell gewissheit dass das
werbeverbot für abtreibung nur
aufgehoben werden soll um das verbot der
abtreibung selbst in frage stellen zu
können nach feministischen phrasen wie
man gebe frauen die hoheit über den
körper zurück hat es familienministerin
paus unverblümt ausgesprochen zitat
deshalb wollen wir auch ein
schwangerschaftsabbruch auch einen
zweiten schritt gehen und eine regelung
für den schwangerschaftsabbruch
außerhalb des stgb treffen zitat ende im
klartext grundsätzliche straflosigkeit
für alle abtreibung ohne not zerstört
die koalition ein für viele menschen
ohnehin nur schwer erträglichen
kompromiss denn angesichts von rund
100.000 offiziell gemeldeten
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen pro jahr
stellt sich doch ein falls die frage wie
das lebensschutz konzept verbessert
werden kann nicht wie man es zerschlägt
wenn klar ist dass § 209 10 ta nur ein
vorwand ist
dann versteht man plötzlich den sinn
dieser debatte bei der es gerade nicht
nass pacte die rechtssicherheit
informations oder beratungs defizite
oder eine eingeschränkte versorgung geht
das ist nur ihr vorwand bei der anhörung
im ausschuss hat mich die
sachverständige frau professorin angela
köninger beeindruckt einerseits
lehrstuhlinhaberin für frauenheilkunde
und geburtshilfe andererseits direktorin
eines re natal zentrums mit über 3.500
geburten pro jahr sie hat überzeugend
dargelegt dass es eben gerade kein
informationsdefizit gibt vielmehr ein
wegfall von § 209 10 a ein dammbruch
wäre
und
sie hat auch erklärt warum viele ärzte
keine abtreibung durchführen nicht aus
angst vor dem strafrecht sondern weil es
ihnen schwerfällt gesunde und
lebensfähige kinder im mutterleib zu
töten wenn sie in anderen fällen darum
kämpfen schon kinder zu retten die
gerade 300 gramm wiegen
in rechtlicher hinsicht gibt es zunächst
keinen verfassungsrechtlichen
handlungsbedarf möglich wäre es den
anwendungsbereich einzuschränken nicht
aber die vorschrift völlig aufzuheben
weil der gesetzentwurf zu einem
unauflösbaren wertungswiderspruch führt
und es gibt eben auch ein zusammenhang
zwischen werbeverbote und
beratungskonzept denn dieses
ergebnisoffene aber auf das leben
gerichtete beratungskonzept wird durch
den wegfall des werbeverbots
unterminiert richtig ist dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht in seiner
grundsatzentscheidung § 209 10 nicht
erwähnt hat der grund liegt jedoch darin
dass diese vorschrift auch nicht
gegenstand des verfahrens war und es
handelt sich nicht um ein kontaminiertes
relikt aus der ns zeit denn anderenfalls
hätte 976 die sozial-liberale koalition
diese vorschrift bei der verschiebung
von damals 219 a zu 219 wohl kaum mit
nur geringfügigen änderungen inhaltlich
aufrechterhalten aber es braucht dieses
märchen um die aufhebung aller hierzu
ergangenen urteil scheinbar zu
rechtfertigen in wahrheit aber die
gewaltenteilung in verfassungswidriger
weise zu durchbrechen zum recht der frau
auf sexuelle selbstbestimmung gehört
auch eigenverantwortlich sorge dafür zu
tragen dass sie nicht schwanger wird
wenn sie das nicht will aber das recht
auf sexuelle selbstbestimmung
in dieser diskussion als rechtfertigung
für die vorsätzliche tötung gesunden
ungeborenen lebens heranzuziehen macht
deutlich dass für sie der schutz des
ungeborenen lebens überhaupt keinen
stellenwert hat niemals hat deutschland
eine willkommenskultur für ungeborene
kinder dringender gebraucht als unter
dieser regierung vielen dank
[Applaus]
ja man hat und herren sehr viele
zwischenrufe große erregungspotenzial
hier im hause nicht nur bei dem afc
räder da kennt man das ja schon aber
das thema reizt natürlich in beiden
seiten da sind die meinungen einfach ein
diametral auseinander wie seltenen
anderen themen lisa paus jetzt die
bundesfamilienministerin von der bundes
grünen
[Applaus]
heute ist ein großartiger tag
in diesem land ein tag an dem ich voller
empathie auch an all die frauen denke
die jahrzehntelang exakt 89 jahre lang
an den folgen dieses gesetzes gelitten
haben und bis heute unter den schweren
folgen des sogenannten werbeverbote für
schwangerschafts abbrüche leiden
allein
weil die nicht den zugang zu den
informationen erhalten haben auf dem sie
ein recht haben nämlich das recht auf
ärztliche auskunft wie sie unter den
schutz ihrer gesundheit eine ungewollte
schwangerschaft beenden können
dieses recht ausgerechnet dieses recht
ausgerechnet das hat der § 209 10 a
vereitelt und werbung allerdings wie es
dieser paragraph formuliert darum ging
es eben nie meine damen und herren
ungewollt schwangere frauen suchten
vielmehr rad und ärztinnen und ärzte
wollten aufklären über verschiedene
methoden und medikamente über vorzüge
über risiken und auch über
komplikationen geben je nach
körperlicher und seelischer verfassung
der schwangeren der § 209 10 a er hat
stattdessen erstens ein zutiefst
menschliches ereignis nämlich eine
ungewollte schwangerschaft
unmenschlich sanktioniert und bestraft
er hat sich gezielt über
wissenschaftliche forschungen und über
medizinische standards erhoben auch
juristin halten die § 209 10 a solange
für über kommen aber sie müssen bis zum
heutigen tage dieses recht anwenden
und drittens zu guter medizinischer
beratung und versorgung von schwangeren
hat dieser paragraph eben auch unnötig
steine in den weg gelegt und mit all dem
wird nun endlich schluss sein damit
mit der abschaffung des 219 endet
endlich die jahrzehntelange
stigmatisierung und kriminalisierung von
ärztinnen und ärzten das signal an sie
lautet heute sie können endlich beraten
und aufklären wie sie es für richtig und
wie sie es für geboten halten
gesundheits und selbstbestimmung von
frauen das sind menschenrechte und wir
machen heute den weg genau dafür frei
und ja ich finde auch im jahr 2022 muss
man auch über den paragrafen 218 reden
und deswegen mit dieser bundesregierung
eine kommission dafür ein
im übrigen halte ich es nur folgerichtig
dass im medizinstudium künftig auch die
methoden eines abbruchs geleert werden
medizin technisch und medikamentös
denn frauen ärztliche versorgung die ist
mehr als ultraschall als kreißsaal und
als krebsvorsorge
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
abgeordnete wir haben gemeinsam für die
abschaffung des 219 mal gestritten zwar
gemeinsam mit auch gästen heute auf der
tribüne ein ganz großes dankeschön an
die bündnisse von proteus an die
ärztinnen und ärzte an pro familia an
die awo an die djb und an viele andere
sie haben über jahre gekämpft sie haben
sich an feinden und bedrohen lassen sie
mussten prozesse führen und doch immer
an der seite der frauen haben sie
gestanden die den weg zu ihnen gesucht
haben sie haben allen parteien druck
gemacht und dank ihres bewundernswerten
einsatzes dürfen sich frauen künftig
darauf verlassen endlich sagt kundig
beraten und unterstützt zu werden
ganz großes dankeschön
und ich freue mich auf tiefstem herzen
dass die koalition aus spd grünen und
fdp nun den weg frei macht für sie für
die ihre patientinnen und für alle
frauen in deutschland dargestellt
die bundes familie ist dann ist auch
bundesfrauenministerin und ihrer freude
hat sie reichlich ausdrücke geben das
recht auf herzliche auskunft wird nur
mit der streichung des paragrafen 219 a
erreicht hat sie gesagt das scheint mir
nicht ganz gelegt die ärztlich auskunft
hätte man immer kriegen können heidi
reicheneck jetzt für die linksfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe frau ministerin ja
heute ist ein großartiger tag weil wir
endlich § 209 10 a strafgesetzbuch
abschaffen
seit über 90 jahren sorgt dafür dass
informationen über schwangerschaft abo
für strafbar sein können dieser
paragraph ist damit nichts anderes als
schikane von schwangeren und ärztinnen
nichts anderes als eine entmündigung von
frauen und nichts anderes als ein
versuch frauen körper zu kontrollieren
das 219 heute endlich verschwindet ist
ein hart erkämpfter und längst
überfälliger schritt
ist es aber nur ein erster schritt denn
das grundproblem ist und bleibt die
regelung von schwangerschaftsabbrüchen
im strafgesetzbuch konkret in prag 218
der besagt dass schwangerschaftsabbrüche
grundsätzlich strafbar sind und nur
unter der erfüllung bestimmter
voraussetzungen straffrei bleiben das
ist ein skandal
die kriminalisierung von schwangeren und
ärztin muss endlich aufhören wir müssen
nach 219 endlich auf 218 abschaffen das
fordert auch unser antrag ein
schwangerschaftsabbruch auf wunsch der
betroffenen ist keine straftat ich kann
das gar nicht auf genug sagen und wir
waren hier auf dem gebiet der heutigen
bundesrepublik auch schon mal weiter in
der ddr gab es ab den 70ern eine
deutlich achtung liebe fdp liberalere
lösung bis zur zwölften woche konnte
sich eine frau selbstständig nach einem
gespräch mit ihrem arzt oder ihrer
ärztin für einen abbruch entscheiden
jetzt wird sie zu externen zwangs
beratung geschickt und muss mindestens
drei tage auf den eigentlichen eingriff
warten der eingriff und die
nachversorgung wurden damals von der
krankenkasse bezahlt heute kostet 1 1
oft mehrere hundert euro abbrüche
konnten in zahlreichen praxen
durchgeführt werden frei ärztinnen wahl
heute müssen frauen teils 200 km und
mehr fahren um ärztin zu finden die
einen abbruch überhaupt anbieten und ja
natürlich mein verhütungsmittel
kostenlos und nicht nur aufgabe der
frauen
leider leider blieb nicht bei ihr
selbstbewusste selbstbestimmten
entscheidungsmöglichkeit liebe kollegin
schwangerschafts abbrüche werden immer
stattfinden die frage ist wie sicher
sind sie und wie stark ist die belastung
für die betroffenen die
gesellschaftliche stigmatisierung die
durch die strafbarkeit verfestigt wird
muss endlich gebrochen werden warum gibt
es denn so wenig ärztin die den eingriff
anbieten warum wird das nicht in den
lehrplänen gelernt warum erzählen mir
denn sophie die frauen davon dass sie
eben nicht wussten was während der
prozedur in ihrem körper vorgeht waren
waren schockiert von den folgen dieser
medikamentösen abtreibung weil sie keine
informationen gefunden haben keine
vernünftige informationen das kann
einfach nicht sein aber gut ich weiß sie
können sich nicht über die zunge
abbeißen halt zu geben dass die ddr und
gesellschaftspolitisch doch dann schritt
voraus werfen wir einen blick über die
grenzen in schweden können frauen bis 18
woche in denen man bis zur zwölften
woche ohne irgendwelche voraussetzungen
zu erfüllen ein schwangerschaftsabbruch
durchführen lassen ähnliche regelung
gibt es in 20 weiteren europäischen
ländern nix mit strafgesetzbuch irland
hat sich von einem der restriktivsten
länder zu einem der liberalsten
gewandert wir sehen also änderung ist
möglich man mag es kaum glauben
auch in spanien werde die reproduktiven
rechte der frauen gestärkt abgesehen
davon dass ab ob sie dort sowieso bis zu
14 woche legal sind sollen sie jetzt
auch in allen staatlichen krankenhäusern
durchgeführt werden und die dreitägige
wartezeit wird entfallen und in
deutschland müssen wir verzweifelt darum
kämpfen dass wenigstens informationen
frei zugänglich sind dabei hat das eu
parlament schon vor einem jahr gefordert
dass auch in deutschland
schwangerschafts abbrüche legalisiert
und hürden abgebaut werden müssen auch
die vereinten nationen und die
weltgesundheitsorganisation kritisierten
deutschland dafür hier nicht aktiv zu
werden von wem müssen sie das denn noch
alles hören
der gang ins land aber es war heute
diesen wichtigen schritt gehen möchte
ich bei aller kritik natürlich auch
gebührend würdigen heute ist ein großer
tag für die selbstbestimmung aller
frauen in diesem land und deswegen danke
ich allen gästen stellvertretend für den
kampf so vieler menschen wir können hier
tolle reden halten anträge stellen und
auch mal abstimmen aber nichts gerade in
diesem bereich funktioniert ohne euren
unermüdlichen druck aus der
zivilgesellschaft ohne euch funktioniert
nichts deswegen danke für euren einsatz
und eure werden gemeinsam weitermachen
nächste rednerin für die fdp fraktion
kathrin helling plan
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren ich weiß nicht wer von
ihnen sich selbst bereits näher mit der
frage der abtreibung auseinandersetzen
musste und es geht mich auch nichts an
mir ganz persönlich ist es erspart
geblieben
ich habe eine solche notsituation in
meinem näheren umfeld jedoch vor einigen
jahren erlebt ich habe mit besprochen
und abgewogen alternativen aufgezeigt
bedingungsloses verständnis gehabt und
schließlich die hand gehalten viele
menschen in unserem land wissen besser
als ich was es heißt wenn eine situation
zu geraten in der man sich die frage
stellt ob es richtig ist ein
schwangerschaft zu beenden seit damals
und seit ich selbst schwanger war eine
situation in der frauen ja gleichsam
darauf programmiert sind eine enge
bindung zu dem in ihren wachsenden
babybauch zu bauen bin ich absolut
überzeugt dass ich keine frau die
entscheidung für eine abtreibung leisten
da
als gesellschaft muss es sein frauen
partner familien in solchen schweren
situationen zu unterstützen ihnen zur
seite zu stehen das bedeutet explizit
keine und jetzt noch mal die ohren
gespitzt an die kollegen von union und
reift lee bevor sie weiter tatsachen
verdrehen keine abkehr vom lebensschutz
konzept des bundesverfassungsgerichts
denn zudem und normative einkleidung
immer gratis
bis zum 19 strafgesetzbuch stehen wir
als freie demokraten aber betroffenen
nicht alleine zu lassen heißt eben auch
sind sie mit ihrem großen
informationsbedürfnis nicht alleine zu
lassen sondern vielmehr zu gewährleisten
dass sie bestmöglich und umfassende
informationen erhalten und das auch
unter ethischen gesichtspunkten
möglichst zügig es besteht also
gleichsam ein informationsgebung da
erscheint es doch geradezu aus der zeit
gefallen wie das nämlich unerträglich
dass wir mit § 29 10 a strafgesetzbuch
ein mit strafe bedroht desinformations
verbot haben das zudem noch besonders
ärztinnen und ärzte in die zange nimmt
die eu zweifelsohne eigentlich besonders
befähigt sind über medizinische
sachverhalte zu informieren und zu dem
die berufsgruppe sind die gelobt hat
höchsten respekt vor dem leben zu haben
hästräger
kollision im afc mit verlaub wer
behauptet der ampelkoalition ginge es
hier um etwas anderes als um sachliche
information der band fehler den
gesetzentwurf nicht gelesen oder erhält
sich oder er verhält sich vorsichtig
formuliert unruhig unredlich denn
schutzlücken entstehen nicht aber nun
zum schluss danke an die kolleginnen und
kollegen aus den ampel fraktionen und
besonders auch minister buschmann für
dieses tempo gut dass paragraf 292
strafgesetzbuch heute endlich fällt
nächste rednerin für die
cdu/csu-fraktion susanne hier
zusammen hier ist mitglied im
rechtsausschuss für die unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen eigentlich habe
ich gedacht wir sprechen heute über 219
und nicht über 218 aber scheinbar habe
ich das falsch verstanden und
ich möchte auch mal festhalten ist es
heute ein großartiger tag für alle frei
ich weise das flair
und wenn wir über die abschaffung des
119 aussprechen und damit die
abschaffung des werbeverbots für die
schwangerschaft auf drücke ich dann gilt
es im auge zu behalten
wir haben intern immer zwei
rechtssubjekte die in diesem fall
konkurrieren beide sind von der
verfassung geschützt es ist einmal die
schwangere frau mit ihrem recht auf die
selbstbestimmung und es ist andererseits
das ungeborene kind das noch nicht für
sich selbst sprechen kann mit seinem
recht auf leben und auch das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht klargestellt
diese rechte gilt es zu achten und die
schutzbedürftigkeit des gegeneinander
abzuwägen
jeder darf der schutz des ungeborenen
lebens völlig negiert noch darf das
selbstbestimmungsrecht der frau in einer
ausnahmesituation verneint werden § 209
10 ist teil der bestehenden und durch
das bundesverfassungsgericht
bestätigten lösung bei der entscheidung
über die zulässigkeit eines
schwangerschaftsabbruch
es ist teil eines hart errungenen
kompromiss der auch zur befriedung des
gesellschaftlichen konflikt um das thema
beigetragen
und weiter schafft 219 rechtssicherheit
der regel nämlich ganz klar welche
informationen zu einem
schwangerschaftsabbruch
gegeben werden dürfen wir sind daher der
meinung dass verbesserungen der
derzeitigen rechtslage und die stellen
die nicht in abrede nur innerhalb der
bestehenden regelung erfolgen können und
ein argument dass die ampel immer bringt
für die streichung des paragraphen aus
dem strafgesetzbuch ist dass es
rechtssicherheit für ärztinnen und ärzte
gibt und ärztinnen ärzte würden der
schwangerschaftsabbrüche vornehmen mit
dieser streichung und ich sage ihnen
genau das gegenteil ist der fall
entgegen der ursprünglichen pläne 219
komplett er komplett zu streichen wird
die regelung nun ins heim wettbewerber
gesetz aufgenommen es macht den eindruck
als haben sie im letzten moment kalte
füße bekommen und
zweifel an der verfassungsmäßigkeit der
ersatzlosen streichung
mit der aufnahme in das
heilmittelwerbegesetz wollen sie nach
den anmerkungen im gesetzentwurf
verhindern dass in zukunft um sachliche
oder gar anpreisen die werbung betrieben
wird
das gesetz selbst verwendet aber nur den
begriff der irreführenden werbung
können sie mir vielleicht fahre was
unter diesem begriff irreführend zu
verstehen
welche informationen und
veröffentlichungen können ärztinnen und
ärzte denn in zukunft rechtssicher geben
ich gehe davon aus dass sie mir keine
antwort darauf geben können sie
verweisen aber auf einen unbestimmten
rechtsbegriff und über die genaue
auslegung also darüber was angemessene
aussagen und informationen zum
schwangerschaftsabbruch sind werden wohl
die gerichte entscheiden müssen ich wage
die prognose dass wir dann wieder an
dieser stelle stehen mit der gleichen
diskussion und zieht die komplette
streichung dieses neuen paragrafen
fordern werden rechtssicherheit meine
damen und herren sieht anders aus
darüber hinaus die das
heilmittelwerbegesetz bei einem verstoß
gegen die irreführende werbung eine
freiheitsstrafe von bis zu einem jahr
vor ihr ziel die ärztinnen und ärzte vor
dem strafrecht zu schützen haben sie
damit also nicht erreicht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der ampel
koalition viele ihrer anderen gesetz wie
viele ihrer anderen gesetzesvorhaben
stellt sich der vorliegende entwurf als
ein ideologisch getriebene und schlecht
durchdachte stockwerk sei
wenn ein tank rabatt fehlschlägt weil
sie die auswirkungen ihrer
gesetzesentwürfe nicht bis zum ende
bedenken dann ist das ärgerlich
verbrennt in selb schlimmsten
vollenhoven steuergeld aber im
vorliegenden
experimentieren sie mit einem höchst
sensiblen thema das auch in der
gesellschaft sehr kontrovers gesehen
wird und riskieren dass die alten gräben
wieder aufreißen
es gibt nicht nur schwarz und weiß wie
sie das gerne hätten da will jede
gesetzesänderung wohl überlegt sein dass
heute ideologie niemals vorrang vor
vernunft haben und vor allem sollte die
neue regelung mehr rechtssicherheit
schaffen als die vorherige stimmen sie
für einen verantwortungsvollen rechts
damit zur abwägung
interessen der schwangeren frauen drohe
rechtssicherheit für ärztinnen und ärzte
und für ein verbessertes
informationsangebot stimmen sie unserem
antrag auf änderung des 200 1918
219 zu erwischen
nächste rednerin für die spd-fraktion
sonja ich wähle
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen der
demokratischen fraktionen und sehr
geehrte besucherinnen und besucher
insbesondere liebe ärztinnen und ärzte
und vertreter von beratungs
informationen hier im haus bei dieser
debatte und verbunden damit auch einen
großen dank für ihre leistungen in den
vergangenen jahren
sie haben einen großen verdienst an
deinem kurz befohlenen streichung des
paragrafen 219 a sie haben in den
letzten jahren unter großem persönlichen
herausforderungen vielen frauen in
persönlichen notsituationen geholfen und
sie haben dies auch getan in einer
situation wo wir eine politische
mehrheit hatten aber in der regierung
nicht handeln konnten wir sind sehr froh
dass wir das jetzt
angehen aber sie haben schon sehr lange
ihre tätigkeit für unsere gesamte
gesellschaft ausgeübt
werte kolleginnen und kollegen mit der
streichung von § 209 10 wir eine
überholte und kriminalpolitisch
verfehlte strafvorschrift endlich in die
vergangenheit denn es ist doch absurd
dass die kriminalisierung von
informationen über eine legale leistung
zur erfüllung eines staatlichen
versorgungsauftrages im strafgesetzbuch
steht das kann nicht sein das darf nicht
sein diese regelung muss gestrichen
werden und deshalb ist es eben auch sehr
sehr wichtig dass die strafurteile
aufgehoben werden und eben die
kriminalisierung der ärztinnen und ärzte
endlich beendet wird es ist vergleichbar
mit anderen tatbeständen gehen dieses
erfolgt ist
um zu dem die informationsfreiheit
wirklich zu gewährleisten haben wir im
parlamentarischen verfahren erreicht
dass im schwangerschaftskonfliktgesetz
eine zusätzliche regelung aufgenommen
wird das tatsächlich durch ärztinnen und
ärzte informiert werden kann weil wir
eben mitgekriegt haben dass einige
länder daran gearbeitet haben die
berufsordnung der ärzte so zu ändern
dass informationen weiterhin untersagt
werden nur die streichung tut es deshalb
nicht deshalb ist es wichtig hier auch
eine positive
informationsfreiheit gesetzlich bundes
rechtlich zu verankern
und werte kolleginnen und kollegen von
der unionsfraktion
die vermischung der begriffe von
sachlicher information
und von werbung ist nicht zeitgemäß das
kann man nicht machen und es ist
rechtlich geregelt dass werbung auch
eine gewinnerzielungsabsicht haben muss
die hier nicht besteht das hat die
öffentliche anhörung die wir gehabt
haben wer wir beigewohnt haben auch
ergeben es ist sogar wenn man das
wirtschaftlich sagt ein minusgeschäft
ärztin und ärzte weil sie für die
leistungen die sie vornehmen dem
versorgungsauftrag den sie erfüllen
weniger bekommen als sie tatsächlich da
reinstecken von daher ist diese
gewinnerzielungsabsicht
insbesondere beiseitezulegen unserer ein
falsches bild von ärzten und ärzte sie
doch leben retten die doch beraten
können die doch diese information am
besten bereitstellen können von daher
bitte ich sie auch da ihre entscheidung
noch einmal zu überdenken das
selbstbestimmungsrecht
der frauen muss gestärkt werden mit
sachlichen informationen setzen wir auf
den und autorin informationen von
radikalen abtreibungsgegnerin
insbesondere im internet etwas entgegen
der minister hat dies ausgeführt heute
ist ein guter tag auch als
rechtspolitikerin ein schritt zu mehr
informationsfreiheit ein schritt zum
modernen strafrecht und ich freue mich
als frau als teil der ampelkoalition und
als sozialdemokraten dass wir dies nun
endlich gemeinsam durchsetzung vielen
gegen die rechtspolitische sprecherin
der spd sonja eichwede war das in dem
heutigen gesetz wird auch das
heilmittelwerbegesetz verändert denn so
ganz traut die ampel der sache wohl doch
nicht der darin soll festgestellt werden
dass keine reißerische werbung etc
stattfinden darf wir das allerdings
wiederum festlegt das ist im gesetz
nicht geregelt beatrix von storch
heute die axt an den ethischen
grundkonsens unserer verfassung und
unsere christlich abendländischen kultur
dieser grundkonsens lautet jedem leben
kommt würde zu auch dem ungeborenen
leben und jeder mensch hat das recht auf
leben und auch der ungeborenen menschen
diesen grundkonsens unserer werteordnung
zu zertrümmern sie und sie feiern dass
das ist das erschütternde dabei es ist
ja hass und freude die uns im mark
erschüttert
die kohle der abtreibungs bewegung
christina hähne spricht nicht von einem
menschen oder von leben sie spricht von
schwangerschafts gewebe das ist die
entmenschlichung des menschen und
deswegen reden sie hier auch alle von
den interessen der frau an informationen
und an den werbe interessen von den
ärzten aber so gut wie niemand von ihnen
niemand redet über das recht des
ungeborenen
menschen auf sein leben das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat
festgestellt der mensch besitzt vom
ersten moment seine entwicklung an ein
recht auf leben und anspruch auf schutz
seines lebens diesen schutz wollen sie
den ungeborenen nehmen spd und grüne
machen daraus überhaupt gar kein hehl
während der justizminister uns versucht
weiszumachen dass die streichung von zu
19a keine auswirkungen auf das
lebenskonzept desto 18 hat frau paul
brown ist da sehr viel ehrlicher vielen
dank dass sie so offen damit umgehen sie
sagt die streichung des 19h hat
signalwirkung und im nächsten schritt
soll dann also die abtragung außerhalb
des strafgesetzbuches geregelt werden
das heißt abschaffung des 218
abschaffung des lebensschutzes der
ungeborene mensch als schwangerschafts
gewebe das wollen sie herr buschmann
geben sie das doch bitte endlich
wir fordern sie auf den schutzauftrag
des verfassungsgerichtes endlich ernst
zu nehmen
schwangerschaftskonfliktberatung muss
persönlich passieren und ich als zoom
konferenz- und sie muss dem schutz des
lebens dienst und der staat muss über
die würde und die schutzwürdigkeit des
ungeborenen lebens aufklären sie wollen
die rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes ignorieren
wir wollen sie umsetzen wir stehen mit
unserer forderung auf dem boden des
grundgesetzes und auf dem boden unserer
christlich abendländisch kultur und sie
nicht sie werden jetzt gleich in jubel
ausbrechen wenn dieses gesetz durchgeht
aber vergessen sie bitte bei ihrem jubel
nicht erstens sie können durch jubeln
weil sie leben und 100.000 kinder in
diesem land jedes jahr werden niemals
jubeln können weil sie nicht leben
werden vielen dank
nächste rednerin für bündnis 90/die
grünen tisch aus
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin die
kolleginnen kollegen liebe gäste im
dezember 2017 stand die angeklagte
ärztin christina händel auf der wiese
draußen vor dem bundestag und übergab
uns abgeordneten eine petition mit über
150 tausend unterschriften und der
forderung fahrrad 219 a stgb streichen
weil sie und etliche ersten jahre lang
immer und immer wieder von
abtreibungsgegnern verklagt wurden und
zwar deswegen weil sie ungewollt
schwangere patientinnen sachlich über
schwangerschafts abbrüche informierten
viereinhalb jahre und einen
regierungswechsel später lösen wir grüne
spd und fdp zusammen mit den linken
heute ein wo auch sehr viele warten wir
streichen den strafrechtsparagrafen 219
und zwar ersatzlos
schluss mit der kriminalisierung
sind erstens die bi verbrecherin vor
gericht stehen mussten schluss damit
dass frauen der zugang zu direkten
ärztlichen informationen aus erster hand
verwehrt wird weil sie ein recht darauf
haben kolleginnen kollegen die
streichung des § 209 10 a schafft
rechtssicherheit für mediziner in und
stärkt die selbstbestimmung von frauen
das ist überfällig und sehr richtig
dafür so lange zu kämpfen das sage ich
sehr klar wäre ohne den mutter ärztin
und ohne starke bündnisse nicht gegangen
ich und wir sagen danke euch allen
stellvertretend an christina händel nora
saß natascha niklas bettina garmann
kersten artus das bündnis für sexuelle
selbstbestimmung die studios und drs for
choice alicia bayer danke dem akf den
vielen juristinnen dem djb und den
beratungsstellen das ist auch euer
erfolg
liebe kolleginnen zu legen die mehrheit
der menschen in unserem land befürwortet
die streichung von 219 er ist ein symbol
geworden auch für die selbstbestimmung
von frauen selbst bei den
gerichtsverhandlungen gießen und kassel
bei denen ich dabei war hatten richter
innen mit der verurteilung nach 219 a
mir ist über die ganzen jahre in vielen
auseinandersetzungen hier im bundestag
eines sehr klar geworden sie von der
union fahren bei 219 a und auch bei 218
einen gefährlichen kurs sie schüren
misstrauen gegenüber ärztinnen sie
misstrauen frauen einer ärztin in die
ausübung ihres berufes reinzureden weil
sie abtreibungen vornimmt ist falsch
einer ungerecht schwangen ihre
selbstbestimmung abzusprechen als wäre
das normal ist und bleibt falsch zu
unterstellen dass vor leichtfertig mit
der entscheidung gegen eine
schwangerschaft umgehen ist falsch sie
als leicht beeinflussbar abzustempeln
das machen sie immer wieder was ist das
bitte für ein fatales bild das sie immer
und immer wieder von frauen beschreiben
2018 habe ich eine sachverständige der
katholischen kirche gefragt welchen
unterschied ist für eine frau die einen
schwangerschaftsabbruch macht denn
ausmache wo dieser geregelt sei sie
antwortete er müsse auch deswegen im
strafgesetzbuch bleiben
damit eine frau sich schuldig fühlt
und genau deswegen ist das signal heute
so wichtig die streichung von 219 a
bricht auch mit einem tabu die botschaft
ist wir trauern frauen wir trauen ihnen
darum geht einen staat der
menschen bewegt
die versorgung und als schwangerer als
gute gesundheitsversorgung
wertzuschätzen das ist zeitgemäß aber
kolleginnen und kollegen angesichts des
drastischen rückgangs von über 50%
ärztinnen die abbrüche machen können
müssen wir die versorgungssicherheit von
frauen verbessern ein
schwangerschaftsabbruch gehört nicht ins
strafgesetz ungewollt schwangere
brauchen eine gute versorgung überall im
land so meine damen und herren an dieser
stelle müssen wir ziemlich hart
aussteigen ein wichtiger tag für die
frauen aber offensichtlich sehen dass
annalena baerbock svenja schulze etwas
anders sie haben natürlich auch wichtige
politische themen der
bundespressekonferenz da geht es um die
gemeinsame gemeinsam für
ernährungssicherheit deutschlands
beitrag gegen die hungerkrise auch
chemnitz mit der landwirtschaftsminister
ist dabei und parallel wie gesagt hier
zum bundestag jetzt das in der
bundespressekonferenz das werden wir
ihnen jetzt zeigen annalena baerbock
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich stehe heute vor ihnen nicht nur als
frauenpolitische sprecherin der fdp
bundestagsfraktion
sondern vor allem als junge und
selbstbestimmte frau und wie sie sehen
können bin ich in freudiger erwartung ja
ich werde im herbst mutter und das ist
für mich
die entscheidung ein kind zu gebären
habe ich gemeinsam mit meinem partner
getroffen aber ebenso gibt es in unserem
land viele frauen die mit anderen
umständen und schicksalen konfrontiert
sind eine möglichkeit die informierte
entscheidung zu treffen zu können
braucht es in unserer gesellschaft für
alle menschen genau darum geht es in der
heutigen debatte
wir wollen in der heutigen abstimmungen
schwangeren frauen eine selbstbestimmte
und eine gute beratende entscheidung
ermöglichen die streichung von 219 ist
dabei alleine die abschaffung des
werbeverbots für schwangerschafts
abbrüche und nicht wie ich heute schon
einige male hören musste das in zukunft
reißerische werbungen für abtreibung
möglich sein wird oder genauso wenig
dass quasi im automatismus der paragraph
218 abgeschafft werden soll die
entscheidung eine schwangerschaft zu
beenden ist für jede frau in unserem
land immer eine höchst emotionale
entscheidung und eine entscheidung die
die betroffene meist jahrelang begleitet
in solchen situationen müssen die
betroffenen medizinische informationen
direkt auf den webseiten der ärzten und
ärzte bekommen sie müssen sich
vertrauensvoll beraten lassen können
deshalb dürfen wir frauen ganzen und
erst in unserem land in solchen
situationen nicht länger alleine lassen
wenn wir damen und herren die
abschaffung des paragraphen 219 a sowie
die anpassung der
schwangerschaftskonfliktberatung
dringend notwendig sondern längst
überfällig vielen dank
nächste rednerin für die cdu csu
fraktion dorothee bär
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
was für eine debatte
es geht heute in dieser debatte um zwei
menschen es geht um die frauen und um
die kinder in dieser debatte und mich
bestürzt es wirklich dass das thema kind
von der ampel so gut wie gar nicht
vorkommen in ihren reden
und er
bundesfamilien entschuldigung der
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann hat
angekündigt es geht ausschließlich um
219 a und 218 spielt gar keine rolle und
die bundesfamilienministerin sagt
natürlich geht es um 218 ich war
ehrlicherweise der überzeugung dass sie
auch deswegen so schnell sich auf ihr
erstes großes familien politisches
vorhaben haben verständigen können herr
buschmann mal ne große einigkeit
herrscht und entweder ist es so dass sie
uns heute nicht ganz die wahrheit gesagt
haben dass es auch der fdp in wahrheit
natürlich um einen steinbruch geht
tatsächlich auch danach sofort 218
einzugehen oder es gibt da auch keine
einigkeit und ich würde mir wünschen
dass das noch mal vorgestellt werden
die fragen vorher kündigt dass es mit
der streichung der forscher vor der
vorschrift ohne vordergründig bessere
informationsmöglichkeit gibt aber die
informationsmöglichkeiten sind doch
jetzt schon vorhanden und es gibt
selbstverständlich auch jetzt schon
rechtssicherheit für alle zehn- oder als
tee und ich finds stoffel frau aus
wirklich scharfe uns unterstellen dass
wir das anders sehen würden das tun wir
nicht wir haben ganz ganz großes
vertrauen in das singen und ärzte aber
wir haben eben auch eine verpflichtung
alles gegeneinander abzuwägen und es
geht natürlich um die frauen aber es
geht eben auch um die kinder und ich
würde mir wünschen dass es von der
anteil bei diesem thema etwas
ernsthafter zugeht ich sage ihnen ganz
offen an die spd-bundestagsfraktion
gerichtet ein bisschen mehr
ernsthaftigkeit und weniger partyfeeling
wer wirklich angemessen
jetzt ist
dreimal viermal fünfmal kontrolliert ob
das video der spd-bundestagsfraktion
wirklich ein von einem fake account
kommt bruder vom offiziell spd
bundestags kann das fände das zu
walzerklängen dass gesagt wird dass
heute ein großartiger tag wird das von
einem schönen moment die rede ist aber
dass mein tag sehen wie du machen und
dass sie drüber schreiben dieser freitag
mit einfach umwerfend was ist den
umsätzen daran in einer dilemma
situation sage ich ihnen ganz ort machen
[Applaus]
und am schluss von diesem video zu
walzerklängen ein grinsen rolf mützenich
der natürlich hier glücklich dann schaut
ich sage ihnen ganz offen ich kenne
keine frauen ich kenne viele frauen die
sich diese abwägung nicht leicht gemacht
haben die aus einer abtreibungsklinik
den party kanonen sprechen und sagen ich
bin wirklich und es ist ein guter tag
für deutschland da es ihnen jeglicher
moralischer kompass abhanden gekommenen
vorstellen
hier
als gegenpol
bundestagsfraktion uns diese debatte nie
leicht gemacht ich habe es an den
herausragenden rede und auch meine
kolleginnen elisabeth winkelmeier becker
und susanne hier heute schon gehört wir
werden ab zwischen dem
selbstbestimmungsrecht der frauen was
und wir werden eben auch ab was es mit
ungeborenem leben was eben dann nicht
mehr die chance hat auch auf die welt zu
können und ich hätte mir einfach
gewünscht warum hier dauernd so männer
aggressiv rein kontakte
vorher
er hätte einen moment starten sie eine
zwischenfrage oder bemerken aus der
fraktion der grünen nein es geht hier es
geht hier um eine sachliche diskussion
wir haben auch gesagt wo besteht
verbesserungsbedarf
wir haben einen antrag vorgelegt wir
haben heute schon darüber gesprochen
dass eigentlich noch einmal eine
kommission angekündigt war und alles was
die machen ist dass wir und das muss man
leider gottes auch mal der bevölkerung
und allen zuschauerinnen und zuschauern
sagen diese koalition plant im anschluss
an diese debatte auch einen empfang eine
feier eine party und hat dazu auch
partygäste eingeladen und das ist etwas
was ich in den letzten 20 jahren so noch
nicht erwähnt habe man kann sich mal
über ein gesetz rheuma kann sich freuen
wenn man die rentenerhöhung durchsetzt
man kann sich vielleicht freuen bei
einer neuen sozialleistung aber eine
party zu feiern nach so einem
gesetzesentwurf sind
etliche stände löst den den ich nicht
kannte ist meine taktik in keiner bronze
freuen die wünsche ein
die schwierige entscheidungen zu treffen
haben eine sachliche eine heute eine
hilfreiche hand keine party kanonen und
für mich ist das heute als frau als
selbstbestimmte frau als mutter von drei
kindern kein glücklicher tag als
zwischengang
nächste rednerin für die spd fraktion
kamen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen der
demokratischen parteien sehr geehrte
damen und herren man kann es nicht
häufig genug sagen gerade nach der rede
vor allem auch die wir gehört haben
heute ist ein guter tag
es ist ein guter tag der ersten und
kraft in abschnitt vornehmen weil sie
endlich nicht mehr kriminalisiert werden
schöne grüße auf die tribüne schön dass
sie da sind es ist ein guter tag für das
selbstbestimmungsrecht von frauen weil
sie endlich den zugang zu informationen
erhalten die sie brauchen um eine
differenzierte und gute entscheidung zu
treffen in einer schwierigen situation
ihres lebens
und heute
ist auch ein guter tag für meine partei
die spd für die streichung von 219 a
haben wir alle gemeinsam schon so lange
gekämpft und sind immer wieder
gescheitert wenn wir gleich dieses
gesetz beschließen dann wird es nicht
nur alte wunden heilen sondern für uns
ist es auch der moment in dem wir mal
wieder merken dass es sich immer lohnt
weiter zu kämpfen und für politische
forderungen
unermüdlich einzustehen
mit dem protein tag machen wir endlich
einen großen schritt dahin alte
konservative und nicht mehr zeitgemäße
vorstellungen zu reformieren wir
schreiten damit in eine neue
gesellschaftspolitische ebene
es ist
und das sage ich auch noch mal sehr
gerne ein schöner moment ich weiß das
ist nicht meine kollegin wege da standen
sie aus der fdp-fraktion an
zwischenfrage oder zwischenbemerkung
nein danke
ich weiß dass es nicht allen in diesem
plenum so geht das haben wir gehört in
den letzten monaten und wochen und ja
auch heute konnten wir immer wieder
erleben dass die debatte um die
streichung von 219 emotionalisiert und
auch gerade wieder verfälscht wird da
geht es dann auf einmal um das zur
verfügung nicht mehr um das
zurverfügungstellen von informationen
sondern um werbung da geht es auf einmal
nicht mehr um den 219 a sondern unter
schutzkonzept des ungeborenen lebens da
wird von konservativer seite ärztinnen
und ärzten unterstellt kein interesse am
wohl ihrer patientin sondern lediglich
an einer eigenen finanziellen
bereicherung zu haben david selbst in
bayern von abtreibungs industrie
gesprochen total absurd gerade da wo die
nächste klinik für abtreibung bis zu 200
kilometer entfernte
deswegen seit hier noch einmal ganz klar
gesagt erstens schon jetzt die
durchführung von
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen nicht rentabel
niemand wird jetzt und auch in zukunft
mit der vorname dieses eingriff reisch
werden zweitens wer behauptet dass nun
reißerische werbung für abbrüche möglich
wird er hat unrecht schon jetzt sind
klassische werbung für medizinische
eingriffe verboten dritten 219 ist nicht
teil des unmittelbaren schutz konzept
des ungeborenen lebens das
bundesverfassungsgericht nennt den 219
seinen beiden entscheidungen zu dem
thema kein einziges mal aber genau wegen
dieser argumentation strukturen die an
der wirklichkeit vorbei gehen und nicht
zugänglich sind für sachliche und
faktenbasierte diskussionen reicht es
leider nicht nur den 219 a zu streichen
um zu verhindern dass konservative
länder die landesärztekammer verordnung
nutzen und dort proaktiv das informieren
über abbrüche zu verbieten haben wir uns
dafür entschieden auch das
schwangerschaftskonfliktgesetz zu ändern
wir stellen damit sicher dass unser
gesetzgeberischer wille nicht umgangen
werden wird wir regeln wir noch explizit
das ist einrichtung gefordert
gewann sie die herzen kerzen gestattet
ist sagt nicht und berufsbezogen zu
informieren und dazu gehört die methode
das medikament die wirkstoffe und die
nebenwirkung und das selbstverständlich
nicht nur persönlich sondern auch
öffentlich auf der homepage ist traut
dass wir das explizit regeln müssen
wir aber viel von dem was wir heute
entscheiden gerade bei frauenrechte
immer mehr eingeschränkt werden auf der
welt wir zeigen heute dass wir einen
anderen weg beschreiten an der seite von
frauen für frauen und für mehr
gerechtigkeit in dieser gesellschaft ich
brauche die argumente sind ausgetauscht
lasst uns 219 streichen vielen dank
die nächste rednerin auf opa hat das
wort so einer kurzintervention caroline
bachmann aus der fdp-fraktion
frau präsidentin vielen lieben dank frau
wege eine frage an sie ich habe gesehen
sie sind mutter sie haben eine tochter
sie sind hier sehr euphorisch und
freudig in bezug auf die abschaffung des
§ 209 10 arm ihre ganze fraktion freut
sich die ganze zeit schon und bejubelt
das sie wollen eine feier feiern sie
können eine feier fallen das ihr gutes
recht ich hätte gerne eine frage an sie
gestellt und ich hoffe sie können wir
das beantworten sie an ihre vorrednerin
sprechen darüber wie schwer es ist als
frau die ungewollt schwanger geworden
ist sich zu informieren sich damit zu
beschäftigen ob eine abtreibung ansteht
oder nicht sich mit den vor und
nachteilen zu beschäftigen und ich sage
ihnen die information die gibt es am
markt die kann man bekommen eine frau
stellt fest nachdem monat dass sie
schwanger ist und es gibt
beratungsgespräch und es gibt
informationen und sie tun ja so als gebe
es in deutschland keine abtreibungen
wissen sie wie hoch die zahl der
abtreibungen in deutschland ist
durchschnittlich
100.000 babys werden abgetrieben ich
möchte sie fragen ist die zahl bekannt
und was genau wollen sie bewerben
frage 1 und frage 2 ist
wissen sie dass ungeborenes leben
schützenswert ist und dass mit beginn
von der schmerz und samenzelle ein leben
entstanden ist mitgefühl und seele ist
ihnen das bekannt und werden sie die
frauen auch darüber beraten
vorwege sie haben die möglichkeit zu
antworten
ja vielen dank erstmal für die
aufklärung über
befruchtungen und all das
ist tatsächlich schon passiert als ich
jünger war
vielleicht etwas erst ganz am anfang
klar zu stellen wir haben heute einen
empfang nach der debatte und kommen mit
der zivilgesellschaft zusammen um den
austausch zu treten
das vielleicht vor weggeschickt
ansonsten weiß ich auch nicht was meine
mutterschaft mit der debatte heute hier
zu tun hat
und ich persönlich habe mich
selbstverständlich mit dem thema
auseinandergesetzt welche prozesse man
durchlaufen muss wenn man einen abbruch
vornimmt ich war in kliniken die
abbrüche durchgeführt haben ich habe mit
vielen menschen aus der
zivilgesellschaft gesprochen mir ist
durchaus bewusst wie das passiert und
ich möchte auf einen logikfehler in
ihrer argumentation hinweisen wenn sie
doch schon sagen dass die information
überall vorhanden sind dann macht es
einfach gar keinen sinn warum warum es
eine berufsgruppe geben sollte die eben
nicht informieren darf ein die die
expertise haben das wären die ärztinnen
und ärzte
ich kann die argumente nicht
nachvollziehen ich habe es am ende
meiner rede gesagt ich glaube die
argumente sind dann auch ausgetauscht
vielen dank
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen sondern bei
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe damen und
herren es ist in der tat ein besonderer
tag
und zwar weil wir uns jetzt
getrieben durch menschen die auf der
einen seite davon betroffen sind diese
informationen brauchen auf der anderen
seite davon betroffen sind weil sie
dafür vor gericht gestellt und
kriminalisiert wurden und weiterhin von
menschen für die das weiterhin ein
problem ist dass menschen kriminalisiert
werden weil sie in einer konfliktlage
sich entscheiden das wollen wir ändern
mit dem heutigen tage auch mit dem
ausspruch weg mit 219 a wollen wir als
gesetzgeber rinnen eine situation für
die gesellschaft verbessern und das ist
doch erstmal gut meine damen und herren
was in der debatte noch nicht so oft
beleuchtet wurde ist dass es hier um
familien geht wenn sie sich die zahlen
anschauen dann sind es familien planungs
themen dass familien sich entscheiden
häufig familien die schon kinder haben
ob sie noch die kraft haben ein weiteres
kind auf die welt zu bringen das sind
täter die mit entscheiden
dass die frauen diese medizinische
behandlung durchführen lassen und dann
ist es doch auch ihr anspruch dass die
das auf eine art und weise durchführen
können wie wir es uns erwarten von
menschen die medizinisch aufgeklärt
werden und auch ein anspruch auf
medizinische aufklärung haben meine
damen und herren wir können das doch
nicht hier voneinander trennen und ich
finde es wirklich sehr grenzwertig frau
wie sie sich selbst hier auch
instrumentalisieren um einer debatte
letztlich aus dem weg zu gehen dass
menschen diesen bedarf haben dass es
menschen gibt die diese lebensrealität
haben und damit lassen sie die frauen im
stich und die väter und die männer und
die kinder die unsere unterstützung
brauchen wir sind doch hier gesetzgeber
die antworten finden müssen oft die
lebensrealität der menschen meine damen
und herren darum geht es doch hier heute
und morgen
diese scheindebatten wie sie die welt
gerne hätten in ihrem bei den bayern ist
auch teil des problems seien sie doch
mal ganz ehrlich ich habe eine zuschrift
von einem älteren arzt der gerne in den
ruhestand gehen würde sich das aber
nicht leisten kann weil dort keine ärzte
die versorgung der frauen und der
menschen sicherstellen können dass ist
doch die realität in deutschland und die
wollen wir ändern meine damen und herren
nächste rednerin für die spd-fraktion
josephine ort
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe gäste auf
der tribüne heute machen wir das zu
geschichte was gesellschaftlich schon
längst der vergangenheit angehört wir
schlagen ein neues kapitel der
selbstbestimmung auf endlich streichen
wir 219 an
und
ich weiß viele fragen sich zu recht
warum wir erst heute zu dieser
entscheidung kommen die argumente liegen
seit jahren auf dem tisch gutachten der
sachverständigen wurden erstellt und der
druck der betroffenen war immer hoch
diesen menschen können wir heute sagen
dort wo es keine konservativen
bremsklötze mehr gibt wird
fortschrittliche gesellschaftspolitik
endlich zur realität
für uns als spd fraktion war immer klar
219 muss weg wir haben die fahne für
selbstbestimmung hochgehalten auch bei
gegenwind heute machen wir mit der
streichung drei
selbstverständlichkeiten ganz klar
frauen entscheiden selbst über ihren
körper
selbstbestimmung braucht information und
keine verfolgung ärzte märz bewerben
nicht sie helfen in schwierigen
situationen
obwohl dies so selbstverständlich
scheint versuchen sie liebe kolleginnen
kollegen von der union die debatte und
gab es heute wirklich wieder gehört
immer wieder mit dem argument der
werbung zu verzerren oder zu verfälschen
so sehr sie auch versuchen die wahrheit
zu verdrehen
wenn eine ärztin auf ihrer homepage über
schwangerschafts abbrüche und die
angewandten methoden informiert
dass der aufklärung der patientinnen und
hat nichts mit anpreisung oder
kommerzialisierung zu tun
und überhaupt und das ist für mich
wirklich auf das erschreckendste von all
dem was wir jetzt von ihnen gehört haben
was ist denn das für ein frauenbild was
dahintersteckt wenn sie den paragrafen
219 beibehalten wollen hoffen sie
heimlich wenn sie frauen
frauen entscheiden sich gegen einen
schwangerschaftsabbruch wenn man sie
bloß im dunkeln lässt über methoden das
ist ihr frauen will für uns ist klar wer
den freien zugang zu informationen
versperrt der will eine freie
entscheidung verhindern
und wir setzen hat spd fraktion aus
information und aufklärung und nicht auf
bevormundung und angst es ist doch ganz
offensichtlich wir haben schon gehört
keine frau trifft eine so weitreichende
entscheidung ob sie ein kind austragen
will leichtfertig niemand denkt so
unbeschwert über einen
schwangerschaftsabbruch nach wie über
einen handyvertrag oder ein neues kleid
diese behauptungen sind lächerlich und
schlichtweg für diese vielen frauen
verletzend
als ehrenamtliche landesvorsitzender
programm ise sei erlebe ich täglich dass
es für frauen immer schwerer wird
arztpraxen und kliniken zu finden in
denen schwangerschaftsabbrüche
durchgeführt werden im saarland gibt es
wirklich kaum noch ärztin ich glaube es
sind zwei die diese medizinischen
leistungen durchführen deutschlandweit
werden diese weißen flecken immer größer
schon jetzt müssen frauen auf dem land
teils hunderte kilometer fahren diese
weißen flecken sind flecken der
unsicherheit der angst und der
entmündigung wenn medizinerinnen und
mediziner strafrechtliche verfahren
fürchten müssen wenn sie von
fundamentalen abtreibungsgegnern
regelrecht verfolgt und persönlich
angegriffen werden ist der schaden für
diese ärztinnen groß für die frauen und
für uns als gesellschaft in zukunft
können ärzte nicht mehr strafrechtlich
verfolgt und an den pranger gestellt
werden nur weil sie eben ihren job
machen ich bin sicher das wird auch die
gesundheitliche versorgungslage für
frauen verbessern liebe kolleginnen und
schon wieder haben versucht das recht
der frau auf körperliche
selbstbestimmung für politische zwecke
zu missbrauchen
und immer gab es mutige die für ihre
rechte gekämpft haben diesen kampf
müssen wir weiterführen denn um nichts
weniger geht es heute vielen dank
nächste rednerin für die spd-fraktion
tina rudolf
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der
demokratischen parteien sehr geehrte
damen und herren liebe zuschauerinnen
auf den tribünen dass der paragraph 219
aus dem strafgesetzbuch heute fällt ist
längst überfällig es war nie richtig
dass es diesen paragraphen gar aber erst
recht gehört er nicht in dieses
jahrhundert es gehört sich nicht ein
paragrafen zu haben der es unterstellt
man könne über schwangerschaftsabbrüche
nicht angemessen informieren ohne dass
das in werbung ausartet in anstößige
werbung und überhaupt unterstellt dass
jemand vorhatte auf anstößige art und
weise sich mit einem so ernsthaften
thema zu befassen und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass dieser paragraf der
vergangenheit angehören wird
es ist aber auch richtig und das zeigt
die debatte die wir geführt haben dass
es sich um eine stellvertretende theater
handelt eigentlich geht es darum wie wir
gesellschaftlich mit
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen umgehen und ob
wir davon ausgehen dass die unter
gewissen umständen möglich sein müssen
und es ist die frage wenn eine frau sich
in einer notlage befindet in einer
situation die sich in ihrer entscheidung
nie einfach machen wird die für keine
frau einfach ist dann müssen wir zu dem
schluss kommen dass es möglich sein muss
diese entscheidung auch zu treffen und
wir sagen ja wir auch der soziale
bereich koalition sagen ja dann muss es
möglich sein diese entscheidung auch
treffen zu können
und wenn man zu diesem schluss kommt ist
es dann nicht nur folgerichtig dass auch
die information über diesen angriff über
diesen eingriff zugänglich sein muss ist
dann nicht folgerichtig dass diese
informationen zugänglich sein müssen und
dass frauen die in dieser notlage sind
diese information auch finden ohne dass
wir es ihnen schwer machen und auch hier
sagen wir ja ja das ist unsere
gesellschaftliche verpflichtungen
und die band kollegen von der union wenn
sie wirklich noch ein bisschen hinweise
in sachen evidenz brauchen ist es ja
angesprochen worden dass sie erst mal
prüfen wollen ob es wirklich zu
schwierig ist diese information zu
finden und ich glaube die tatsache wenn
man sich die liste der bundesärztekammer
anguckt und die man durch telefoniert es
gibt personen die das gemacht haben und
da allein schon falsch einträge findet
nummern ins mehrere leere laufen dann
ist das der beweis dass es eben nicht
möglich ist so wie es sein sollte diese
informationen zu finden und der
eigentlich wesentliche punkt ist aber
dass es an einer solchen situation nicht
davon abhängig sein sollte ob ich eine
solche liste finde es kann nicht sein
dass in einer solchen situation das
darüber entscheidet ob eine entscheidung
informiert getroffen werden kann und
deswegen müssen wir einen besseren
zugang zu diesen informationen schaffen
und vor allem müssen wir auch für
diejenigen zu kriminalisieren die genau
dafür sorgen die aufklären und sie sich
da ihre verantwortung sehr sehr groß
bewusst sind
der zweite liga ab dass man sich einfach
mal hier bemerken das ist ja ihr
ehemaliger gesundheitsminister
abgeschafft hat fünf millionen für eine
studie zum sogenannten post überraschend
rom aufschlagen zu wollen ein konzept
nach seit den 80ern durch diverse studio
meta analysen widerlegt ist das ist die
auffassung der evidenz der union ich bin
froh dass wir damit heute abschließen
eingesetzt haben den letzten jahren das
zugang zu informationen auch zu ganze
schwangerschaft abbrechen möglich ist
ich weiß dass wir hier nicht aufhören
dürfen dass wir in den nächsten jahren
sonst auch vor dem problem stehen werden
dass viele der ersten und ärzte wie
christina jene die das aus überzeugung
gemacht habe zum beispiel auch aus
fachrichtungen nicht aus der gynäkologie
sondern zum beispiel auch der
allgemeinmedizin in zukunft in den
ruhestand gehen werden und dann ein
wirklicher versorgungsengpass droht
deswegen ist es so wichtig was wir heute
machen dass wir gesellschaftlich diese
frage diskutieren und das wir
gesellschaftlich noch mal klar machen
dass schwangerschaftsabbrüche möglich
sein müssen dass niemand sich diese
entscheidung leicht macht aber dass wir
auch in anderen ländern ganz genau sehen
dass ein restriktiver zugang nicht zu
weniger schwangerschaftsabbrüchen führt
sondern zur unsicheren schwangerschaft
abbrechen und das gilt es zu verhindern
das werden wir die stadt
für geldspenden
was unterstreicht dass wir frauen diese
entscheidung zutrauen dass eine
entscheidung der betreffenden ist und
dass niemand diese entscheidung abnehmen
kann dass wir gesellschaftlich die
verpflichtung haben für gute
rahmenbedingungen und dann auch für eine
gute medizinische versorgung zu sorgen
dass es unser frauen und unser
menschenbild und dafür stehen wir und
darauf bin ich heute sehr stolz
ich schließe die aussprache wir kommen
zur abstimmung über den von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur änderung des
strafgesetzbuchs der männer und herren
und jetzt sind wir wieder live im
deutschen bundestag ein bisschen hat er
ausstieg entschuldigen sie bitte dafür
aber wir wollen ihnen dass er jetzt mit
ein ist es durchaus ein historisches
urteil
219 a die mehrheit der ampel wird jetzt
hier abstimmen für die abschaffung unter
buchstabe a seiner beschlussempfehlung
auf drucksache 2404 den gesetzentwurf
der bundesregierung auf drucksachen
1635 und
1980 in der ausschuss fassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um ihr handzeichen
das ist die fraktion die linke die spd
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen fdp
gegenstimmen
die cdu csu fraktion die fdp fraktion
enthaltungen sehe ich nichts damit ist
der gesetzentwurf in zweiter beratung
angenommen dritte drittel beratung und
schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
das sind die fraktionen die linke die
spd fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen und
die fdp fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
das ist die cdu csu fraktion und die fdp
fraktion enthaltungen sehe ich nicht
enthaltung sich nichts damit ist der
gesetzentwurf angenommen
ja und meine damen und herren sie sehen
ist denn im ovations
die abgeordneten schauen rauf auf die
tribüne da sitzt unter anderem die
ärztin handle die 2017 der auslöser war
für die letzte reform im jahr 2019
verurteilt worden weil sie werbung
betrieben hat auf ihrer seite für
abtreibungen und 2009 10 hatten sich cdu
csu und spd noch einmal auf eine
novellierung geeinigt jetzt aber die
abschaffung des paragraphen
219 a nachher wird es einen großen
empfang geben auch mit den versammelten
ärzten und ärzten und die linke des
hauses die linke hälfte des hauses muss
ich sagen hat für diesen abschaffung
gestimmt auch die linksfraktion aus der
opposition nur gegen stimmen von cdu csu
und fdp und eins kann man jetzt schon
voraussagen es ist der anfang einer
debatte gewesen die sicherlich in dieser
legislatur weitergeht und 218 steht ja
auch noch im raume zumindest die
bündnisgrünen fordern hier eine
novellierung beschaffung sowie die
linksfraktionen die heute hier ebenfalls
einen eintrag antrag eingebracht in dem
sie auch die abschaffung
des paragraphen 218
fordert